so you're probably here because you
think you suck at rocket league maybe
you've been struggling with some aspect
of your game your solo queue ranked
matches haven't been going super well
and you can't really figure out why well
i'm here to tell you that everybody goes
through struggles in rocket league
especially when solo queueing there's a
reason the professional players are so
good they have likely been playing
together for a really long time whereas
when you're solo queuing you're likely
meeting your teammates for the first
time we all suck at rocket league no
matter how many hours we put into the
game but i'm here to give you guys the
best advice i possibly can when it comes
to solo queuing in rocket league if
you're looking for a more personalized
experience head over to my twitch
channel where i stream almost every day
welcome to my making rocket league
easier series let's get into the video
hey guys do you have a large penis then
if you enjoyed this awesome video make
sure to like and subscribe thanks
so my first piece of advice when solo
queueing rocket league is to not solo
queue if you can help it rocket league
is designed around team play and trying
to perform well with players you don't
know anything about is the easiest way
to have a bad ranked experience but i do
know that for some people you have to
solo queue there could be a million
reasons you have to solo queue and can't
play with your friends that's totally
fine and i understand you wouldn't have
clicked on this video if you were
playing with your friends every day more
than likely but i'm here to tell you
that you're in for a rough road if
you've decided to solo queue rocket
league especially ranked rocket league
but i would advise you to use the party
up feature if you can we've all had
those solo queue matches where you and
your teammates just do not vibe well
together at all but there is those
occasional matches where you guys mesh
well together and everything goes
according to plan so when this happens
try and use the party up feature i know
the rocket league community can be quick
to leave matches most of the time but
you never know if you don't try and you
may even meet your next rocket league
partner or potentially even a new friend
my next piece of advice is to use the
first minute of the game to analyze the
quality of the match and what i mean by
quality is to look at what your
teammates and the other team is capable
of doing how well is the other team
playing together how are you and your
team playing together are your teammates
rotating properly are they chasing or
playing defensive just use the first
minute to get the overall vibe of the
match if your teammates are playing
aggressive it's probably a good idea to
play back and defend most of the match i
know this is boring and can get super
annoying but sometimes you gotta do what
you have to do to get the job done and
win the match same for the opposite
situation if your teammates are playing
passively make sure you're playing the
ball when you need to this gives you a
solid green light to play fast where
you're needed but is never a reason to
ball chase in fact there is never a
reason to ball chase if you need to
chase down a ball it means you're in the
wrong position or you were too slow to
analyze the situation it shows that
you're panicking and is a great way to
make the game harder on yourself and for
your teammates speaking of making the
game harder a lot of solo q players make
the game as hard as they possibly can on
themselves and the number one way to do
this is by giving up possession of the
ball constantly solo queue players love
to boom the ball across field if
possible especially when they don't need
to
controlling the ball and the play is
always a better option than booming it
away from your team i know it's hard to
trust your solo queue teammates but you
can't win a game on your own most of the
time especially once you get into the
higher ranks carrying a game becomes
harder and harder to a point of
eventually it might become impossible
and you'll need to use your teammates to
get an edge on the match think of each
play as a possession if your team has
the ball more than the other team your
chances of winning the game
skyrocket if the other team can't get
the ball
they can't score on you it's very simple
and it makes a lot of sense but it's
something most players don't really
think of ever in your upcoming matches
focus on the amount of time you and your
teammates have possession of the ball
and if you don't have the ball think
about how you can get it back into your
possession you'll likely find that this
leads to better play from you and leads
to better results with solo queue
teammates
the final piece of advice that i have
for you guys and this is a big one is to
ignore the haters
ignore the toxicity you're 100 percent
going to have to endure when solo
queuing rocky this game is extremely
competitive and when you mix
competitiveness with the anonymity of
the internet and most likely younger
gamers you're going to get toxicity
rampant toxicity so just remember that
no one can judge your own gameplay if
someone thinks you're bad ignore it if
someone thinks you're slow ignore it
someone thinks you're a ball chaser
ignore that too if they want you to play
a certain way just ignore it more likely
than not they're projecting their own
problems onto other players and honestly
it's just super cringe you don't need to
respond and it doesn't even deserve a
response if you're doing your best and
working hard on what you need to work on
as a player then nothing else really
matters you're the only judge of your
own ability and the only people you need
to listen to is your coach the people
who support you and most importantly
yourself so i'd recommend just turning
off game chat entirely most of the time
left goes on the kickoff so you don't
really even need to worry about that i
really hope you guys found this video
helpful make sure to like and subscribe
i really appreciate it helps the channel
out a ton thank you for watching the
video and i'll see you guys in the next
one peace
[Music]
you